(inspirational music)
- We are creating the world's largest
acrylic mural by a single artist.
But I knew that I didn't
want to have just a mural.
It had to be a project
that really dove deeper
into the needs in the
community, and what a perfect
opportunity to do it in these
massive grain elevators.
My name is Armando Minjarez.
And I'm the project director
and curator for Horizontes.
(soft guitar music)
I immigrated to the United States in 2001.
I am an artist, but I've also
been a community organizer
working on mostly immigrant rights.
So, the work that I do now really combines
my work as a community organizer
and bringing that into creative expression
and kind of mixing those two.
Horizontes, it's a large-scale
community engagement art project.
There's another one that was painted
as part of the project, too.
This is painted by
Heather, and these are all
women from the north
end, and these are all
her (speaking foreign language).
The women from her family that grew up
in the neighborhood.
The project really focuses
on bringing solidarity
between the primarily Latino neighborhood
and the historically
African-American neighborhoods.
With these murals, one
of my personal goals
is to have people of
color depicted in the most
magnificent way that we could.
(inspirational music)
The people that are depicted in the mural
are people that used to
live in the neighborhood,
or they currently live
in the neighborhood.
We went and dig through
the historical archives
and pulled photographs
from the people that helped
build the tracks that we're surrounded by.
Those were Mexican laborers
that came 100 years ago.
Thanks to the internet, I've found Gleo.
She had painted some
giant towers in Brazil,
so I knew that she had the skill
and the ability to paint large-scale.
And she flew down from
Colombia into Kansas,
and she's been here
working on the project.
- [Armando] What I hope that
this means to the community
is that we feel proud
of where we come from,
that we take ownership
of our neighborhoods,
of our communities, and
continue to expand this work.
All of us hold different identities.
We're people of color, we're immigrants,
we're queer people, women.
Here we are painting the
world's largest mural,
not because we want to hold the record,
but because it's our
stories that need to be told
and to remind ourselves
that we need to continue
to work together.